اظهرت صور حصلت عليها الجزيره حجم الدمار
الذي لحق بمخيم المغازي وسط قطاع غزه عقب
انسحاب قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
المخيم ورصدت الجزيره محاولات مواطنين
انتشال جثث شهداء من تحت الانقاد في ظل
غياب الامكانيات وعدم تمكن طواقم الدفاع
المدني من الوصول الى هذه الاماكن بسبب
القصف الاسرائيلي
المتواصل لماه حطاها مع الكوم
هذا ايش مش فهم ولا كيف عننا تقريبا فوق
ال 15 16 جثه هي المرمي لا اجانا صليب
احمر ولا هلال احمر ولا دفاع مدني ولا
بلديه ولا اي واحد ا شدنا كل العالم يدفن
الاموات اللي فش غير الكلاب هذ الضاله
والبسا افترست الدنيا هنا تكل من اللحم
الميتين والكلاب صارت تهجم علينا فوان
الامور هذه من كثر ما اكله اللحم هه
متحلله متحلله ه مش عارفين مين صاحبها
ياه قاعد بذب فيع السكينه وماحدش مدور
علينا انا شاهد عيان على مجزره عن دار
العروج الفيضي كان في حوالي 60 مواطن كان
في قاعد جووا الدار كلهم ماتوا يعني احنا
بيوتنا اعز ماملك يعني في مقوى ولا ماكل
ولا مشرب في شوارع قاعدين وين
[موسيقى]
نروح